all right our subject for this morning
the Cure the curse and the Cure what did
I say the curse and the Cure before I
and God spake all these words saying I
am the Lord thy God which have brought
thee out of the land of Egypt out of the
house of
bondage Thou shalt have no other gods
before me Thou shalt not make unto thee
any griven image or any likeness of
anything that is in heaven above or that
is in the earth beneath or that is in
the water under the Earth Thou shalt not
bow down thyself to them nor serve them
for I the Lord thy God am a jealous God
visiting the iniquity of the fathers
upon the children unto the third and
fourth generation of them that hate me
and showing Mercy un to thousands of
them that love me and keep my
Commandments Thou shalt not take the
name of the Lord thy God in vain for the
Lord will not hold him Guiltless that
taketh his name in vain remember the
Sabbath day to keep it holy six days
shalt thou labor and do all thy work but
the seventh day is the Sabbath of the
Lord thy God in it Thou shalt not do any
work thou nor thy son nor thy daughter
thy manservant nor thy maidservant nor
thy cattle nor thy stranger that is
within thy gates for in six days the
Lord made Heaven and Earth the sea and
all that in them is and rested the
seventh day wherefore the Lord blessed
the Sabbath day and hallowed it honor
thy father and thy mother that thy days
may be long upon land which the Lord thy
God giveth thee Thou shalt not kill Thou
shalt not commit adultery Thou shalt not
steal Thou shalt not bear false witness
against thy neighbor Thou shalt not
covet thy neighbor's house Thou shalt
not covet thy neighbor's wife nor his
manservant nor his maidservant nor his
Ox nor his ass nor anything that as thy
neighbors God is
good God is good all the and all the
time is good Psalm 100 verse5 for the
Lord is
good his Mercy is
Everlasting and his truth endureth to
all
generations I thank God for that there's
coming a day when error will cease to
exist truth will endure to all
generations and when I said there's
coming a day when error will cease to
exist also those who are determined to
live their lives by error they will also
cease to
exist God must be worshiped in spirit
finish it for me and in
truth and the only truth is
this and of course it is personified in
in the very life of Jesus Christ I'm
grateful to God for this high honor of
speaking for him and speaking to his
beloved people and my prayer is that the
Lord will put his words in my mouth that
what I say May first glorify God and
then secondly place a blessing on your
lives is there anyone present who is not
a 7thday Adventist M your hand you are
not as oh how very very nice how how are
you tell us your names please would you
mind standing so we can look you
over we're the singers from South
Carolina uh-huh U I am a Baptist yes so
close yes yes yes yes give me the name
again seag spell that for me s g r okay
seagar and my wife Debbie sers Debbie
very nice to have you Let the church say
amen amen that was weak say it again
amen one more time amen God is good and
all the time God is good brother and
sister Seager may the Lord Place a
blessing on your life that's permanent
and that will stay with you until he
ushers you into his kingdom amen thank
you very much for coming is there anyone
else who is not a Seventh Adventist
we're always honored to have
guests all right our subject for this
morning the Cure the curse and the Cure
what did I say the curse and the Cure
before I begin let me ask you very
politely to preserve reverence if you
don't need your phone as a Bible which
it is not then make sure it is not
turned on let me check mine Mr cameraman
sorry for coming out of
focus before you say to me physician
heal
thyself all right it is
off we thank God for technology but it
has two sides one side is good the other
is catastrophic so please preserve
reverence where you are because we serve
and we're worshiping the god of the
universe I'm sure you've been in a
courtroom at some point in your life and
you notice how people behave in a
courtroom they're very quiet they don't
chat and text and whatever else why
because the Earthly judge can send them
on a vacation at the government's
expense are you following me and so
we're very very careful how we conduct
ourselves well well we are in the
presence of the god of the Universe I
leave it at that favor number two while
I'm speaking pray for me and say Lord
put your words in that man's mouth
Jeremiah 1:9 then the Lord put forth his
hand and touched my mouth that's the
Divine God touching my mouth made of
dirt and the Lord said unto me behold I
have put my words in thy mouth and I
want to speak God's words because Jesus
says the words that I speak in to you
they are spirit and they are life he did
not say that about my words and so ask
God and he answer you put your words in
that man's mouth favor number three
think as you listen Isaiah 11:18 come
now let us do what reason together I'm
so comforted by the fact that I serve a
reasonable and a reasoning
God the devil is
unreasonable God is reason aable so he
come to you he'll ask you why are you
angry as in the case of Cain prior to
that he came to Adam where are you he
spoke to uh Jonah when joah sued on the
hillside or the hilltop because God did
not destroy Nineveh God will talk to you
what's
wrong why are you the way you are and so
think as you listen and the spirit of
God will guide that mental activity
let's bow our heads and pray
dear God thank you for the freedom we
have in Christ to come into your
presence if we've offended you forgive
us de God forgive us quickly and
completely wash Us in the blood of
Christ which is his life and remove
every spot and every
stain father I humble myself before you
and I ask you a god find it in your
heart to be with me don't leave me in
the Pulpit by myself because I'll make a
disaster of this entire thing Stand By
Me stand with me and through your spirit
stand in me let my voice be your voice
dear God that those who listen may be
blessed and your name
glorified father wherever your people
are worshiping you now bless them I pray
and if anyone under the sound of my
voice has contracted covid-19 and any of
its variance in the name of the great
physician father heal that person 100%
any other aches and pains your people
have you're merciful de God touch them
remove these afflictions if you choose
not to remove them then grant them
considerable relief I pray but let us as
we ache and we sore and we're in pain
let us cause that to cause us to yearn
for the new world when there shall be no
more pain no more sickness No More Death
bless the seagar de God we're delighted
with their presence touch them in every
every area of their lives so much that
those who come into their presence may
be blessed as well may your spirit be a
permanent member in their home and the
angels patrolling in and out to protect
them and their families now father I
commit this service to your glory and
your glory alone in Jesus name I pray
let God's people say amen and
amen the curse and the Cure it's 11:50
I'll release You by 1230 is that excess
Ive it is excessive oh all right okay
all okay the lord loves the truth okay
by 1230 I'll try to let you go if I go
beyond 12 highly unlikely unless the
Holy Spirit speaks to me very directly
let us go to the Book of Genesis chapter
8 not 8 sorry Genesis 5 we'll read from
verse 28 Genesis 5 reading from verse 28
our subject the curse and the Cure
do you have Genesis
5 we read from first I read from the
King James version so that you may not
think I'm reading strange words if you
have a different
version and limc lived 18 and2 years and
begat a
son and called him Noah saying this same
shall Comfort us concerning our work and
toil of our hands because of the ground
which the Lord hath what
cursed the ground was
cursed Noah LIC named him Noah as a
reminder that mankind needed help to
till the ground which was
cursed let's go to Genesis
8 we read from verse
20 Genesis 8 reading from verse 20 our
subject the curse and the
Cure and Noah build an altar unto the
Lord and took of every clean beast and
every clean foul and offered burnt
offerings upon the Altar and the Lord
smelled the sweet Savor and the Lord
said in his heart I will not again do
what curse the ground anymore for man's
sake so we have another curse the flood
was a
curse and so God said I won't do this
again I'll never send a flood he didn't
he didn't say I'll never destroy the
Earth again I won't do it with a flood
that's the reassurance we have when we
see a rainbow the flood was a curse
we have that curse in Genesis 5 as a
result of uh Cain's sin let's go to
Genesis 4 and see why lmch said the
ground was cursed Genesis 4 we read from
verse
9 do you have that the Lord said unto
Cain where is Abel thy brother and he
said I know not am I My Brother's Keeper
and he said what hast thou done the
voice of thy brother's blood crith unto
me from the ground and now art thou what
cursed from the earth which hath opened
her mouth to receive thy brother's blood
from thy hand when thou tillest the
ground if you have my version read with
me it shall not henceforth yield unto
thee her
strength the ground was cursed because
of Cain's murder of his brother the
ground was cursed because of the flood
we're working back in time let's go to
Genesis 3 we read from verse 17 our
subject the curse and the
Cure don't forget favor number two ask
God to do what put his word this is not
a a a simple request it's a very serious
request one wrong word can read the
message you have Genesis 3 from: 17 and
unto Adam he said because thou Hast
hearkened unto the voice of thy wife and
has eaten of the tray of which I
commanded thee saying
Thou shalt not eat of It Read With Me
Now cursed is the ground for thy sake
the Earth was under a triple curse when
Jesus Christ came the curse because of
Adam's sin the curse because of the
murder of Abel the curse because of the
flood let's take a look at the effects
of sin let's go to verse 16 of Genesis
3 and to the woman he said I will
greatly multiply thy sorrow and thy
conception in sorrow Thou shalt bring
forth children and thy desire shall be
to thy husband and he shall rule over
thee painful childbirth and dictatorial
husbands as a result of
sin let's go to verse 17 and read that
again and unto Adam he said because thou
Hast hearkened unto the voice of thy
wife and H has eaten of the tree of
which I commanded thee saying Thou shalt
not eat of it cursed is the ground for
thy sake in sorrow shalt thou eat of it
all the days of thy life that's a curse
Thorns also and thistles shall I bring
forth unto thee sin affected
botony are you with me what do I mean by
botany plant life sin affected plant
life now certain uh plants produced
thorns and thou shalt eat the herb of
the field verse 19 in the sweat of thy
face shalt thou eat bread what is that
curse hard work to
survive till thou return unto the ground
what does God mean by return unto the
ground die the ultimate in curse for out
of it was thou taken for dust Thou Art
and unto dust shall thou return we have
Painful child birth birth sin affected
the physiology of the woman the
physiology of the man sin affected
botony now we know that the curse upon
Adam or the rebellion of Adam passed to
the animals that is why after the flood
God put the fear of man in animals
because animals would attack and there
were only eight people with all these
animals so God did something to spare
Noah and his
relatives animals affected
physiology
affected botony
affected the whole creation affected by
sin that's why the entire creation has
to be destroyed and a brand new creation
has to be
made 2 Peter chapter 3:10 but the day of
the Lord shall come as a thief in the
night in which the heaven shall pass
away with a great noise and the elmet
shall melt with fervent heat the Earth
also and the works that are therein
shall be burned up the atmosphere was
cursed by
sin don't ask me for details I don't
have how all I know is God needs to
remake the heavens and the
Earth the effect of sin was
comprehensive when we talked about and
thy husband shall rule over thee we're
looking at how it affected social
relationships
ultimately it damaged the image of
God our subject is the curse and the
Cure let me pray again father in Heaven
as I continue my best to speak for you
direct my mind suppress my carnal nature
into subjugation I pray in Jesus name
amen reason with me the Bible says where
sin abounded finish it for me Grace doth
much more abound which means the effects
of
sin must be exceeded by the effects of
what okay you say Grace
Fine the effects of sin must be
exceeded by the effects of
Grace if that's clear say amen amen
let's review the effects of sin
physiology botany social relationships
the ground the atmosphere everything
affected by sin then the Cure for sin
must affect the same
area you're not with me you look as if
you are but you you're
not are you with me then I withdraw my
false
accusation the cure for
sin is
righteousness
amen righteousness must exceed sin and
the effects of
sin let's take a look at
righteousness Proverbs 14:34 let's go
there we look at righteousness in
relation to sin 2 minutes to
12 Proverbs 14:34 you know it very well
do you have that not
yet do you have it now if you have my
version what does that
say righteousness
exalted a nation I finish the verse but
sin come on is a reproach to any people
we have two the two absolute opposites
in that verse identify
them righteousness and
sin the two absolute opposites
righteousness and sin the Bible says
righteousness exalteth a
nation which mean it has to exalt the
nation
socially economically are you following
me you name all the aspects of the life
of a Nation righteousness has to benefit
every aspect of the nation's life in
order for righteousness to exalt a
nation sin is a reproach to any people
and sin in the opposite way negatively
affects a nation or an
individual so we see sin is the opposite
of righteousness
let us go to 1 Corinthians 15 let's read
verse 36 I think it is maybe before you
go there go to Romans 8 let's read verse
10 Romans 8:
10 subject The Cure the curse and the
Cure do you have Romans
8:10 if you have my version you may read
with me and if Christ what be in you the
body is dead because of and the spirit
is life because of righteousness we have
the two opposites
again 2 Corinthians 5:
21 one of the most important verses in
the entire Bible if I had to pick three
important verses that would be one of
them you have 2 Corinthians 5:
211 what does that that verse say for he
hath made him to be sin for us who knew
no sin by the way who knew no sin does
not apply to us it applies to Jesus
Christ for he made him to be sin for us
who knew no sin finish the verse that we
might be made what the righteousness of
God in him we have the two opposites
again the cure for sin finish my Words
is
righteousness the cure for economic
problems is
righteousness the cure for broken
families is righteousness
let's go to Romans
6 welcome those of you coming in welcome
welcome our subject is the curse and the
Cure do you have Romans
6 let's read
18 being then made what free from sin
finish the verse he became the Servants
of righteousness again we have the two
opposites being made free from sin he
became the Servants of righteousness
from serving sin to serving
righteousness those are the two
opposites the cure for the curse is
righteousness and the curse is sin look
at verse
20 we for when what you were what free
from when you were the Servants of you
were free from righteousness again it's
the same thing as Verse 18 when you were
the Servants of sin
you were free empty devoid of
righteousness the curse is sin The Cure
is
righteousness having said that let us go
to
Jeremiah chapter
23 we read five and
six our
subject the curse and the Cure
Jeremiah 5 23 sorry vers 5 and
6 are you there behold the days come
sayth the Lord when I will raise unto
David what a righteous branch and a king
shall reign and prosper and he shall
execute what judgment and Justice in the
earth in his day Judah shall be Sav and
Israel shall dwell safely Now read with
me and this is his name whereby he shall
be called what is that the Lord our
righteousness is
Christ the bread yes or no
yes is Christ the shepherd yes is Christ
the the the door yes is Christ The
Living Water yes is Christ the light yes
above all of that Christ is is the
righteousness
amen it's correct to say righteousness
is more than
something
righteousness is
someone don't ask me to explain I
can't
righteousness is
someone remember Esther
when the threat was made to destroy all
the
Jews go to Esther
5 Esther
5 the curse and the
Cure you have Esther 5 we read verse
two are we
there as
Esther we're the people of the book are
we not or we used to be or we still are
we still are all right let me pray again
father as I continue you continue
blessing me beyond my expectation I pray
in Jesus name amen and it was so when
the king saw Esther the queen doing what
standing in the court that she obtained
what favor in his side and the King did
what held out what to Esther the what
the golden scepter that was in his hand
so Esther did what Drew near and touched
what the top of the septer now we know
from verse 11 of chapter 4 anyone
entering the king's presence and
invited would be
killed when Esther came in and
invited what saved her was that the king
did what he held out the the
scepter Esther's salvation was that
scepter let me
pause so you follow
me Esther's
salvation Esther's protection from the
Wrath of the King was that scepter the
king didn't the King extended the
scepter esta touched it her life was
saved I am the
way the truth and the life no man cometh
unto the father but by me is Christ the
scepter yes or no
yes numbers 24:1
17 what's our subject Cur the curse and
the kill for those of you who came in
recently is is there any non- sday
Adventist among you we want to greet
them no okay all right all right okay
what book did I say numbers what chapter
24 what verse 17 this is the Oracle of
bam it's an interesting thing bam opened
his mouth to curse the Israelites and
outc came blessings you see your enemy
cannot hurt you unless God allows it
that's right I didn't I I didn't say
that clearly let me try to use chattano
English it is only by God's permission
that your enemy can hurt you
and that hurt cannot exceed certain
limits because God will not let you and
me be tested beyond that which we are
able to
endure numbers 24:1 17 bam speaking now
the Bible tells in genes uh numbers 235
and numbers 2316 that God put a word in
Bam's
mouth that's why I always ask God put
one in my
mouth verse 17 chapter 24 of numbers
what does that verse say and I shall see
him but not now and I Shall Behold Him
but not nigh Now read carefully there
shall do
what come a star out ofc and the scepter
shall rise out of yes now who is the
star that comes out of Jacob Jesus
Christ don't hesitate always speak
confidently even when you're wrong who
is the star that comes out of Jacob
Jesus Christ who is the scepter that
comes out of Israel Jesus Christ
now keep this in mind we saw the scepter
was the instrument that saved
Esther go me with me to Hebrews chapter
1 our subject the curse and the
Cure Hebrews
1 it's one of the more fascinating
chapters in The Bible in that chapter
you and I are allowed to EAS drop as the
father talks to the son
it's very interesting chapter God is
speaking to the son and we are
listening verse 8 of Hebrews 1 but unto
the son he saith Read With Me Now thy
Throne oh God is forever and ever a
scepter of righteousness is the scepter
of thy kingdom
stop a scepter of right what is a
scepter it is a Sy symbol of power
position
royalty Supremacy
sovereignty the Bible says that scepter
in the Kingdom of Christ is
righteousness Christ himself is called a
scepter because Christ himself is
righteousness but the what the power in
the kingdom of God is righteousness
because the scepter represents power and
Authority and Rule no wonder in 2 Peter
3:13 the Bible says nevertheless we
according to his promise look for what
new Heavens come on and new earth finish
the verse wherein dwelleth righteousness
as it was before
sin it's good to get a PhD if you're
pursuing
one to buy a house good to buy a car
and since you're God's child when you're
in that car it's a limousine
automatically because you're God's child
are you following me it's not the car
it's you it's good to do all of that but
listen to Jesus seeky first come on tell
me the kingdom of God come on and his
righteousness all the yes that's
Priority One because that is the
cure for the curse
seeky
first since I began by stressing
opposites to seek righteousness is to do
what I gave you a clue I began by
stressing opposites to to seek
righteousness is to avoid
sin The Sermon on the Mount blessed are
the poor in spirit for theirs is the
Kingdom of Heaven Matthew 53 blessed are
they that mourn for they shall be
comforted blessed are the meek for they
shall inherit the earth blessed are they
which do Hunger come on and thirst after
what righteousness finish the verse they
shall be
filled
immunized immunized finish my
Words immunized
against
sin righteousness is the
answer before sin the universe of God
the throb the pulse of that Universe was
righteousness let them make me a
sanctuary that I made do what dwell
among them what was the first article of
furniture made
the ark but what was the purpose of the
Ark to house the Ten Commandments the
great controversy page 433 paragraph 2
El writes the ark was merely a
receptacle for the the the the the
precepts the tables of the law and the
presence of these Divine precepts gave
to it is value and
sacredness let me say differently when a
touched the ark what happened to
him but what did he really touch by
touching the
ark the
law he put his hand on God's
law can't do
that Psalm 119 ver 172 my tongue shall
speak of Thy word for all thy
Commandments that's true but that's not
the word I
want all thy Commandments
are
righteousness M all thy Commandments are
righteousness now Jesus said blessed are
they which do hunger and thirst after
righteousness Now give me another word
blessed are they that do hunger and
thirst after
what give me another words it's a little
longer hunger and thirst after what
obedience
because obedience is
righteousness let me ask you this you
look at me strangely when I said
obedience is
righteousness when Elijah ran from
Jezebel how was he
sustained when he hid in a cave how was
he sustained don't look at me how was he
sustained
this is not
good this is going all over the
world how was Elijah sustained someone
on this side
quickly the birds God commanded
Ravens to feed him the Ravens had to
know who he
was hm what else where he was what else
what time to bring the food and what
food mhm they came morning and evening
now is that obedience yes or no
yes now I'm not saying it's obedience
that leads to Salvation I'm saying
nature finish my Words obeys
God go to uh 2 Chronicles chapter
7 I'm telling you righteousness was the
power before sin that R the entire
universe it still does but we've got a
problem of sin that has to be removed
second chronicles chap 7 let's read from
verse 13 our subject the curse and the
Cure 12:15 on the
dot we have 2
Chronicles nobody answered the guest
preacher you have it all
right let's read from verse 13
are you there if you have my version
read with me if I shut up Heaven that
there be no rain or if I do what command
what the Locust to the stop or if I send
Pence upon my people if I shut up Heaven
the question how does God shut up
Heaven go to Isaiah
5 we're talking about righteousness or
obedience as the principle that
undergoes the entire kingdom of God
Universal as it is Isaiah 5 let's read
from verse
5 do you have that what does that verse
say and now
what I will tell you what I will do to
my keep reading this verse I
will mhm and it shall be and I will do
what else break down M and it shall be
keep reading keep
reading I late waste go
on
uh-huh and I will do what
ah stop I will do what command the
clouds now go back to Second Chronicles
7:13
are you
there if I shut up Heaven that there be
no rain Express that
differently if I tell the clouds don't
drop your
moisture now if God commands the clouds
not to drop moisture what will the
clouds do they'll
obey just obedient
God commanded the Ravens that's what we
read in First Kings 17 he commanded the
Ravens as verily as he commanded the
Widow now the Ravens obey I'm not
calling that righteousness that saves
I'm simply saying that is obedience to
God's
command and the curse is rebellion
against God's
word let's go to
Mark 4 read from verse 37 our subject
the curse and the Cure 18 minutes past
12 should I not tell you the
time I want you to know I respect your
time that's all it
is doesn't take God long to bless people
do you have Mark chapter 4 verse
37 are you there read with me nice and
clear what does it say and there are
arose a great storm of wind and the
waves beat into the ship so that it was
now full and he was where in the hind
the part of the ship asleep on a pillow
come on and they awake him and say unto
him what Master carest thou not that we
perish now let's read carefully verse 39
read with me now and he arose come on
and rebuke the wind keep going and said
unto the sea peace be still
stop what did Christ do to the wind
he rebuked it what about the
sea it's right there it's right there he
said unto it so we have he rebuked the
wind and he said unto the sea he spoke
to
both
now he rebuked the wind said unto the
sea P be S and the wind ceased what did
the wind
do come on speak loudly it obeyed what
did the C do listen to me carefully all
nature obeys God except those Made In
His
Image plants
obey the curse is rebellion against
God's word the curse is
Disobedience The Cure is righteousness
which is obedience in every area of life
now go with me to Romans 6 let's read
verse 16 as we try to close it's
12:20 Romans 6:1 16 I want you to read
microscopically do you have that not yet
yes are we ready know ye not that to
whom yield yourselves servants to obey
his servants ye are to whom you obey
stop notice the word
yield yielding is a conscious
act you don't yield unconsciously you
decide to
yield to those who yield themselves
servants to obey his servants he are to
whom you obey keep reading whether of
sin unto or of all unto we have sin
righteousness again now I want you to
look at that verse very
carefully because you either yield to
one power or the
next which means the choice we really
have is Whom Shall I serve not if I
Shall Serve that's right did I did I say
that clearly our fundamental Choice
isn't should i serve you will serve one
or the other the choice is who shall it
be it's either God or Satan
as in a garden God said Thou shalt
surely die the devil said ye shall not
surely die they had a choice which voice
to follow that has been the case from
then till now even before that Lucifer
falsely accused God the Angels had to
choose his word or God's
word know you not that to whom you yield
yourselves let me ask you this but do
not answer me review your life for the
past 6 months to whom are you yielding
by our choices our words our
expenditures our
associations our
diet our Recreation to whom are we
yielding I ask you don't to answer me
you do your own review it's your private
business between you and God to whom you
yield yourselves servants to obey his
servants you are to whom you obey
whether of sin unto
death will be obedience unto
righteousness I love this verse very
much it's so powerful and clear
sin
death
righteousness uh sin unto death
obedience unto righteousness so we have
sin leads to death obedience righteous
that's how we should have done it sin
death obedience righteousness are you
with me sin leads to obedience is MHM
now look at the these two sin and
obedience and let's look at the first
two sin and
death no sorry sin and
obedience death is under sin what are
these two things
opposites sin obedience opposite then we
have death what do we have over here
righteousness what's the opposite of
death but give me another word for
righteousness life then righteousness is
really
life is the opposite of
death let me say it again
righteousness is life but it is the life
of God lives out of
us that's the
cure for the curse which is sin which
leads to
death notice I said righteousness is the
life of God living what out of us but in
order for that life to be lived out of
us it must first be what placed where in
us now go to Jeremiah
31 Jeremiah 31 let's read verse
33 I may have to sneak past 12:30 please
don't get upset if I do
you have Jeremiah
31:33 read with me
for this this shall be the Covenant that
I will make with the house of Israel
after those days say the Lord I will do
what put my laws where in the inward
Parts come on and uh-huh yeah same
thing that's fine that's same thing put
my law in the inward parts right them in
their hearts essentially the same thing
now from that inward location
H The Life of Christ is lived out now
why do I say the Life of Christ is lived
out because the law is put am I saying
the law is Christ
yes let me pray father I'm coming to the
end but don't end your control of my
thinking dear God please in Jesus name I
pray amen take your mind back to the
sanctuary the sanctuary was surrounded
by a white fence about 9 ft tall what
did that represent
I said it's white what does it represent
the righteous of Christ there was an
entrance what does that represent Christ
you can only come through Christ The
Sinner brought a lamb what do that
represent Christ the altar of sacrifice
Christ the priest who caught the blood
Christ the entrance to the holy Place
Christ the shoe bread Christ the inent
Christ we have no problem let's go to
the most holy place
did you say the sh bread is Christ come
on don't be hesitant did you say that do
you say the light is Christ did you say
the live is Christ did you say the altar
is Christ the lamb is Christ the fence
is now don't stop saying
yes but who's the law
Christ listen to me Christ is the law as
verily as he his righteousness amen
do I understand everything no what I
understand is if he's the
light and he's the bread and he's the
Sheep the shepherd and the lamb and the
water and whatever else and the way the
truth and the life what prevents him
from being the
law and Psalm 119 ver 172 my tongue
shall speak of Thy word for all thy
Commandments come on are
righteousness when the law is written
The Life of Christ is placed within
you because Romans 7:10 and the
Commandment which was ordained to life I
found to be under death because of sin
great controversy page 467 paragraph 3
the law reveals to man his sin but
provides no remedy while it promises
life to the obedient it declares that
death is the portion of the transgressor
the law is
life it may not be an instrument of
Salvation it is life life this is the
life where to live the law is
life and that life is the Life of
Christ The
Curse come on tell me the curse sin The
Cure righteousness that righteousness is
Christ and that life is reflected in the
law of
God Jesus told the Jews John 663 the
words that I speak unto you they are
spirit and there are
life the voice that spoke on sin was the
voice of
Christ and El said when he said to Satan
in Matthew 4:4 man shall not live by
bread alone but by every word he was
referring to the ten
commands obedience my brother and sister
is
life
righteousness is life
the Bible says and it shall be our
righteousness if we observe to do all
these Commandments before the Lord Our
God as he has commanded us obedience is
life righteousness is Conformity to the
law of God by the indwelling power of
Christ this morning we want a booster
shot of the Cure are you following me we
have boosters flying around Society we
need a
booster of
righteousness
mhm God made the world in six days he
could have done it in one one minute one
second but he examples for us the way we
should live day by day day by day day by
day I'm sure God Gave All of Us Grace
yesterday but that was for
yesterday we need Grace for today we
need power for today we need a booster
of righteousness
today and that booster is Jesus Christ
himself so that we should say as the
Apostle Paul I am crucified with Christ
nevertheless I live yet not I but Christ
liveth in me but what is put in me the
law and out of the abundance of the
heart the mou speaketh the hand acts the
feet move whatever
it is what comes out of here and God
puts on the heart of man and woman his
law which is life which is
righteousness that indwelling divine
power which in the sanctuary service
occupy the most sacred compartment of
the
Tabernacle
H are you with
me the outer Court
WEA the altar of sacrifice
fine in the mo in the Holy place we had
a Candlestick incense altar they sure
bread
fine God could have put his law in the
Holy
place he could have put his law in the
outer court all sacred
precincts he could to put his law into
2/3 of a mile That was supposed to
separate the tents from the Tabernacle
fence they were supposed the empty space
of 2/3 of a mile all the way around not
an animal could Grace there
the Holiness of God he put
it in the most holy place now you tell
me what that tells you about how God
views his standard of righteousness
which is his
law otherwi says Christ was both the law
and the gospel he was
both the curse is sin The Cure is
righteous you and I as members of the
7day Adventist church we know from
Revelation 11:19 and the temple of God
was open in heaven and there were seen
in his Temple the Ark of the Covenant
what's the Ark of the Covenant the
container for what the law of God and
that light began to shine
out from the most holy Place God's law
is placed where he himself personally
resides symbolically that's where he
placed and the law was in that box and
the shakina glory sat above it and that
represented the Throne of God the
universal Throne of God is founded upon
law and so Christ said in John
15:10 if you keep my Commandments you
shall abide where in my love even as I
have kept my father's command and abide
in his love my brothers my sisters let
me close by appealing to you seek the
righteousness of
God and the righteousness of God is the
very Life of Christ in us and our you
see the same way a sinner naturally goes
towards sin a genuinely converted person
should naturally move towards
righteousness I didn't say that
properly Jesus Christ said in John 3
verse6 May the Lord give me these final
words please father that which is born
of the flesh
is flesh mhm that which is born of the
spirit is but you have to be born of
either
one some of us are born of the church
not of the
spirit we like what the church stands
for it has a pipe organ and a handsome
pastor and so we
join people are nicely dressed they're
all professionals none of them
unemployed so I join so I can benefit
from that no we must be connected to
Jesus Christ amen are you following me
and so Christ says that which is born of
the flesh that's all it is no matter how
decent it
is that which is born of the spirit is
Spirit that's why I said a genuinely
converted person will naturally strive
to do what's right as verily as an
unconverted person naturally tends
towards
sin because the carnal nature cannot be
more powerful than the spiritual because
we're sin bounds finish my Words Grace
is much more abound we have to believe
that as he thinketh in his heart so is
he my brothers and sisters regardless of
your addiction your battle your whatever
it is you and I may have there is power
to overcome and that power is the
righteousness of Christ and that
righteousness is expressed in his holy
law which is written in our hearts not
the encyclopedia britanica or your
textbook or the church manual just the
law of God and nothing else why because
this is the whole Duty come on of man
and of
angels how many will say with me
Lord help me to hunger and thirst after
righteousness can I use your hand stand
up with
me 12:35 forgive me for exceeding my
limits
help me to hunger and thirst after
righteousness because as verily as Sin
affects every level of existence The
Cure affects every level of
existence as righteousness exalts a
nation it exalts the individual heads
bowed eyes closed father we thank you
for your word if I said anything I
should not have said forgive me God I am
Earth and clay and dirt but you know my
heart I try to speak for you take my
weak effort de god with the work of your
spirit and apply it to the heart of
everyone who
listened give to us father a genuine
thirst for
righteousness righteousness is the Life
of Christ as Express in his holy law
dear God where we have fallen short
forgive us father forgive us and right
now give us a brand new start a start in
the direction of Conformity with your
will and father let obedience to you be
our highest
Joy bless everyone who came as we leave
let us contemplate the words we listen
to
father and let our lives change by the
indwelling power of Christ I say again
father give us an insatiable appetite
for
righteousness under all circumstances
and at all time as your word says in
Psalm 10 6:3 blessed is he that doeth
righteousness at all times bring us back
at the appointed time I pray until then
keep us under the shadow of your wing I
pray in Jesus name let God's people say
amen and amen
[Music]
oh